Noel. Noel!
[Noel] Where are we? Are you a munchkin?
No, of course not.
How do we get back to the tent?
I don't know, I don't have a brain.
That's the QI gig gone.
Look, there's Paul.
[Noel] Paul!
-Hi, Noel. Hi, munchkin.
-I am not a munchkin!
I don't have a heart.
Yeah, that's not gonna come
as a big shock to people.
[roars]
[Sandi] You're bold this year.
-Prue, what are you doing?
-I was late. It's the last costume.
[Sandi] Come on.
[all singing]
♪ Cakes and quiches and pies, oh, my ♪
Wait a second.
I could just click my heels together.
It worked. [laughs]
Are you guys gonna start the show or what?
I had some kind of weird dream.
I'm not sure it was a dream.
Paul still doesn't have a heart.
-[Noel] Business as usual.
-[Sandi] Hmm.
[both] Welcome to
The Great British Baking Show.
-You gonna wear that for the whole season?
-[Noel] I thought I might, yeah.
[Sandi] Yeah, it's a strong look.
I don't think this show
can have too much gingham.
Is it weird that I fancy you now?
[Paul] So do I.
[Noel] The winner is...
[cheers and applause]
[Sandi] It's our 10th anniversary,
but who will be our 10th champion?
[Dan] The first time I saw the tent,
I just thought, "What?"
[Priya] Just the most surreal thing ever.
It's just insane.
[Alice] Very nervous.
I've watched every season,
and to actually be here,
I can't quite believe it.
[Michael] Absolutely terrified.
I baked along last year,
and now it's there. [chuckles]
[Phil] It doesn't seem real yet.
Not until Sandi or Noel says...
-On your marks...
-Get set...
Bake.
[Noel] This year,
we've gone one better.
Really?
...with 13 home bakers
from across the country.
Oh, my days.
[Paul] Tenth year,
we're bringing back the baker's dozen.
It could be any point in the next
nine weeks that two people could leave.
I feel like I've got a sweat on.
Last year, the bar really went up.
This year,
I want to be inspired by those 13 bakers.
And I'm longing to taste what they bake.
[Sandi] This year's challenges
have been carefully devised
to conjure up
some of the most spectacular home baking
the competition has ever seen.
I think everyone's feeling a bit worried
about being the worst.
I keep forgetting
that the Technical's a thing,
obviously 'cause I can't practise it.
And I'm like, "Oh, my God, the Technical,
it's something else to think about."
I think baking and being a vet
do complement each other.
You've got a lot of needles and syringes,
catheters, bits and bobs.
[inhales sharply]
Some more normal than others.
[Noel] Will Paul and Prue
be impressed with our baker's dozen?
[Michelle] Meeting Paul and Prue
is gonna be nerve-wracking.
My belly's in knots.
I've been up in the middle of the night,
saying, "I can't do this."
Just don't wanna be shaking
the whole time.
[David] I once made
a wedding cake for someone,
but I didn't even stick around to hear
how it went, or if it fell.
[Henry] I wouldn't say
I'm a high achiever.
I'd say I achieve certain things,
in sort of the same way
that you can achieve a hangover.
[Sandi] On our 10th anniversary...
-[Phil] Hopefully it'll stay.
-It hasn't fallen over yet.
...in our biggest competition ever.
Mayhem is the best word for it.
[Noel] Who will be crowned the winner...
He's doing the thing.
-[chuckling] Does it work?
-No.
...of The Great British Baking Show?
[Henry] Oh, the shakes. Oh, the shakes.
Must not drop cake.
It's faultless actually.
I'm dribbling.
-Prue, you've gotta stop saying that.
-[both laugh]
[theme music playing]
[Noel] Once again, we've pitched our tent
at Welford Park in Berkshire.
We start with cake week,
and over the next two days,
our new batch of bakers
will face three challenges.
After which, one of them will be crowned
our first star baker
and another will have to leave the tent.
Morning, bakers.
Welcome to your very first day
in the tent.
How marvellous
to see you all looking quite so relaxed.
Now, here is the important thing,
there are 13 of you,
what people used to call a baker's dozen.
-Well, mainly old people I think, yeah.
-Old people.
[Sandi] Er, what it means
is that at any point,
two of you might be leaving the tent.
Could be this week.
Could be the semi-final.
We just don't know.
Now, for your first ever
Signature Challenge,
the judges would like you
to bake a fruitcake.
It can be any size, any shape...
But it must contain
a significant amount of dried fruit.
-Significant?
-Yeah, more than one currant, I think.
-Five?
-Yeah, five is fine.
-Five is significant.
-[Sandi] Yeah. [chuckles]
Now, as well as being perfectly baked,
it must be beautifully decorated.
-You have two-and-a-half hours.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
-Bake!
Finally doing it. Can you believe it?
It's madness.
[Helena] God, I'm freaking out.
I am nervous.
I'm trying to find my measuring thing now.
Oh, my God, I'm in a tizz already.
The fruitcake, for me,
is one of those basics of baking.
Pick a great sponge base,
fill it with fruit,
but it's about the consistency
of the batter.
Too thin, all the fruit
will drop down to the bottom.
Too thick, they all stay at the top.
Get the balance right
and it will bake beautifully.
[Prue] They've only got
two-and-a-half hours.
So, they have to get those cakes
into the oven, out of the oven,
and get it cooled,
because we want it decorated as well.
And there's a real danger that they'll be
putting icing onto a hot cake
and that'll just melt.
Just trying not to cut myself.
It's really sharp.
[Michael] Ow.
I need a plaster from somebody.
[Paul] At this stage,
I think the bakers'll be quite nervous.
But I think every year the standard's
got better and better and better.
And I expect this year
to be exactly the same.
-[Amelia] Hello.
-[Paul] Good morning.
-How are you?
-[Sandi] Morning, morning, morning.
Right, tell us all about your fruitcake.
What are you doing?
So, I'm doing, like, a Christmas cake.
Erm, it's something my mum used to make
all the time when I was a kid.
She'd literally make them in October,
like, soak the fruit beforehand
and then keep pouring brandy in them.
So, to speed things up a bit,
I've put my fruit over heat
and just let it simmer
while I'm getting the cake mix ready.
I do it like you do it.
-Oh, do you? [laughs] Yeah.
-[Prue] I never bother to do it ahead.
[Noel] Amelia is a fashion designer
from Halifax,
and she's been baking with her mum Julia
since she was five.
-Lots of washing up for Mum?
-Yeah.
Great.
[Noel] Her mum's recipe demands
over 700 grams of mixed fruit,
all infused with orange brandy.
That is definitely
a significant amount of fruit.
Yeah, definitely at least four currants.
And obviously,
putting that much fruit in it,
how long are you baking it for?
It's quite a low temperature
for about an hour and 15 minutes.
Fingers crossed.
-Do you think that will be a bit...
-Yeah.
It'll be close, but I think it'll be fine.
Have you finished with the brandy now?
Not yet,
but I'll let you know when I have.
-Thanks, darling.
-Good luck.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Thank you.
[Noel] Amelia isn't the only one
following in the family footsteps.
[Jamie] This is my grandma's recipe
I'm using.
I think she's pleased I'm using it,
I don't know. [laughing]
I don't think she's angry.
[Noel] Five other bakers
are also using recipes
that have been passed down
through generations.
I'm making Bara Brith Teulu Ni,
which is my family's Bara Brith,
and I brought my own eggs
from the chickens
that they laid this week.
I'm hoping secret weapon,
they're just super rich and super tasty.
[Sandi] Michelle grew up
on her parents' smallholding
in Carmarthen, Wales.
She now lives in Tenby with husband Ben,
son Alfie and their three chickens,
Chip, Hawker and Blossom.
[Michelle] This is worse than trying
to herd the sheep.
[Ben] Come on.
[Sandi] As well as their eggs,
she'll use strong tea to soak the fruit
for her family's Bara Brith,
giving it an extra kick,
along with an icing made
with her husband's favourite Welsh rum.
[Michelle] Oh, my God, my husband
actually thinks I look like you.
-Wow. We should play a trick on him.
-Do you think?
-No? Let's play a trick on him.
-Don't we look alike?
Next time you're about to go on holiday...
-What, you go home?
-...I'll turn up at the airport,
go on holiday with him for three weeks,
see if he notices.
-Okay. Yeah, fine.
-[Noel] A pleasure talking to you.
-And say hello to your husband.
-I will.
Well, I'll say hello to him
when we go on holiday together. Okay.
I love a bit of zest.
I am making
my great-grandma Rosie's fruitcake.
I think it does help
to have the family connection there.
You feel like they're with you
holding your hand.
[Sandi] Steph's love of baking
was inspired by her great-grandma Rosie.
Steph is from Chester, and works
at her mum's classic car business.
Can I have one of these?
[Sandi] She's attempting a vintage look
for her citrus and apricot fruitcake,
with candied oranges and marzipan roses
in honour of her great-grandma Rosie.
-Is your great-grandma still around?
-She's not, no.
-Aw.
-But she will find anything.
If you lose anything, just get in touch.
-Really?
-She's on it.
I've lost a pair of socks,
I'm gonna come chat with you.
-[Steph] Excellent.
-I've lost my mind actually.
-[laughs] Erm, not sure...
-I think that's beyond Grandma.
[Noel] When it comes
to channelling Grandma...
[Rosie] That's the mango.
...Steph won't be alone.
I'm making an updated version
of my grandma's
sort of basic, normal tea loaf recipe.
So, I'm adding my own dried fruit,
but what I didn't realise is
when you dry it
just how little it actually weighs,
and so I had to dry more and more
and more and more of the fruit.
I had to finish it off at work,
so I think they think
I'm a crazy person now, but...
[Sandi] Rosie's a vet in Somerset.
And when she isn't drying fruit at work,
she proves dough in the warmth
of her pet python Minnie's vivarium.
[Rosie] Perfect temperature.
[Sandi] As well as adding
her own dried apples,
strawberry and mango,
she's also updating Grandma's recipe
with Indian chai.
Just trying to get as much
of the chai flavour as I possibly can.
Rather than trying to make it look
super fancy, I'm going for tasting good.
So, if that goes wrong, I'm screwed.
One, two, three, four.
[Noel] As Rosie heads east,
she'll have company.
[Michael] When I go to India,
on all the trains
they come through like offering you chai,
and it's, like, the tastiest thing.
[Noel] Raised in Perthshire,
Michael's mum Nicola and dad Sam
have ensured
his Scottish and Indian heritage
were celebrated in his baking
as soon as he could reach
the kitchen counter.
You used to be on your climb-up.
[Michael] Hmm.
[Noel] He's aiming high
with chai spices,
chopped sultanas and apricots,
and a piped henna-style decoration
that will require a steady hand.
Mum texted me at 5:00 this morning,
saying, "Be calm, be slow, be confident."
It's gonna be fine. It's gonna be fine.
I just... Oh, my God.
I've done it again. I'm so sorry.
[Michelle] Michael, again?
[Michael] For goodness' sake,
this is so stupid.
It's the beginning,
everybody gets really stressed.
Less haste, more speed.
Yes.
-[Sandi] Okay.
-[Michael] This has to be the last one.
I don't have many left.
[Noel] But the greatest danger
in this first fruitcake challenge...
My God. I feel like the pressure's on.
...is the fruit itself.
[Henry] Bit more fruit in.
[Noel] Too much
will overwhelm their batter...
I'm getting a bit OCD about my numbers.
...resulting in a stodgy, underbaked cake.
It looks a lot thicker
than when I did it at home.
[Noel] But Dan has made
a last-minute change to his recipe.
I've, like, doubled
my amount of fruit in it today.
Yeah, significant.
Yeah, you said "significant",
I thought, "Uh!"
-So, literally today you've changed it?
-I've changed it, yeah.
[Prue] My concern is whether
you're gonna have time
to bake this now much bigger cake.
Can I just warn you?
This is not a good face, this face here.
[Dan] Yeah, I can tell.
[Sandi] Dan lives
and works in Rotherham,
and is a support worker
for people with learning difficulties.
That's it, a good big blob, Dave.
[Sandi] He'll add
spiced rum buttercream
and coffee and almond brittle
to decorate his now much larger
rum-soaked fruitcake.
I feel like you've got
no room here to operate.
I feel like you just wanna
throw all this on the floor. Watch this.
-There you go.
-[laughing]
Watch this. Watch this.
-There you go. Fly, my pretty.
-Do you know what?
-[Noel] Fly. Look at this.
-[Dan] That works.
-Take your shoes off, get comfy.
-[laughing]
Nail this!
Thank you, sir.
[Sandi]
Whilst Dan's recipe is expanding...
[vocalising]
...David's recipe is missing something.
My fruitcake has no fat.
That's unusual.
I love healthy baking.
[indistinct chatter]
[Noel] David is from Yorkshire,
and when he's not travelling the world
working as an international health advisor
he's fanatical about keeping fit.
[grunts and chuckles]
[Noel] As well as replacing fat
with carrot and squash,
David has found
another healthy alternative for his fruit.
[David] I'm using dried prunes and figs.
[Sandi] It does sound like a cake
that's gonna keep you regular,
-if I may say so.
-[Paul] Oh, yeah, absolutely. Yeah.
Well, yeah, I need that.
-[Paul] Good luck.
-Too much information, David.
-[Paul] Thank you very much indeed.
-Thank you very much. Thanks.
Bakers, you are halfway through
your first Signature Challenge.
Wow, first time call of the season.
-Was I good?
-No.
[Sandi] Now it's the point of no return.
[Amelia] I've used this tin before
where half of the cake stayed in the tin,
and we don't want that to happen today.
[Dan] That's fruitcake, innit?
I don't know what Paul's worried about.
Yeah, I'll show him. [chuckles]
[Sandi] The more fruit they've
added in order to impress the judges...
Come on, please come out good.
...the longer their cakes
will need in the oven.
[Dan] Just hope for the best.
Low and slow,
gonna check it after an hour.
One-sixty for about forty minutes.
-[David] In.
-Oh, that felt good.
So, we're gonna set a timer for 50.
[timer beeping]
Start.
She's in. She's in.
Come on.
[Sandi] But one baker
isn't quite ready to hit the oven.
[Phil] I've just made the marzipan.
Gonna make a ring
around the middle of the cake.
[horn honking]
[Sandi] Phil is a lorry driver from Essex,
where he lives with his wife Angela
and two daughters,
sixteen-year-old Lexie
and eleven-year-old Pippa.
Oh, you want a bit? Tough.
[laughs]
[Sandi] As well as marzipan,
he's adding cinnamon, ginger, nutmeg,
allspice and cloves to a fruitcake
that's become a family project.
[Phil] My wife and I have got
a really good baking relationship,
and she's come up with this sort of idea,
so I just do what she says
like any normal married man.
[Noel] This year's
first Signature Challenge...
So, here we go. Be kind.
...is about to get even trickier.
I'll check the cakes.
[Noel] Whilst constantly checking
their fruitcakes' progress in the oven...
It's not burnt yet.
...the bakers will now need to use
every minute
to create beautiful decorations
the judges have demanded.
[Sandi] And Priya is hoping to impress
by bringing the inside of her cake
to the outside.
This will look better, I promise.
[Sandi] Priya's an aspiring novelist
from Leicester,
and mum to two-year-old Kian
and four-year-old Liam.
[Priya] Oh, that's good.
[Sandi] Her cake will be filled
with dried tropical fruit,
and to decorate, she's handcrafting
oranges and bananas in marzipan.
[Noel] What else are you gonna make?
-It's gonna be a pineapple. Eventually.
-Pineapple.
-It's like a psychedelic snowman.
-[Priya] It is at the moment.
-Yeah, it looks a bit crazy.
-Little hat.
[Priya] Look at that.
[Sandi] Alice is also going
for a stand-out look
with her fruit decoration.
[Alice] So, making
a gingerbread fruit wreath,
and then I'm just gonna cover
the whole thing in gold.
It's gonna be a bit glitzy.
[Noel] Alice works at a school
in central London as a geography teacher,
and uses her baking to help her pupils
with their coursework.
[Alice] So, using your spoons,
you are going to be the waves,
the erosion...
[Noel] Snow-white royal icing
will coat her Christmassy
fruit and gingerbread wreath,
which she's hoping
will pack a gingery punch.
[Alice] And I've added some extra
crystallised ginger,
'cause I absolutely love ginger.
So, I'm just chucking that
all over the place really.
[Sandi] Whilst Alice
looks forward to Christmas...
I'm doing, like, a simnel cake.
...Jamie is already celebrating Easter.
[Jamie] It's gonna have like chicks on it
instead of just balls of marzipan.
That one's called Barney. [chuckles]
[Noel] Jamie is currently on a gap year
and lives in Dorking
with his identical twin brother Alex,
their mum Charlotte
and their baking mentor, dad Pat.
[Patrick] Is that the cake
I taught you to make?
[Jamie] No, it isn't.
[Noel] Jamie's adapted
his nan's traditional recipe
to create a double-layered simnel cake.
-So, you get two layers of marzipan...
-Yeah, exactly.
-...and marzipan on the top.
-Yeah.
-Good, I like a lot of marzipan.
-[Jamie] And then there's like a...
-How old are you, Jamie?
-I'm 20.
-Does your mum know you're here?
-She does.
I'm allowed out. [laughs]
[Noel] When it comes to her decoration,
Helena is getting
into a different kind of holiday spirit.
I live like every day is Halloween.
So, I'm doing bat-wings made out of sugar.
Try to spookify a fruitcake. [chuckles]
[cuckoo clock chiming]
[Noel] Halloween-obsessed Helena
grew up in Lanzarote,
and now lives in Leeds
with her rescue dog Cato,
-husband Will and baby daughter Flora.
-[coos]
Oh, Flora will love it.
[Noel] The caramel bat-wings
will decorate her spooky
spiced pumpkin and maple fruitcake
flavoured with dried prunes
and toasted pecans.
[Helena] They're not right.
It's crystallised the caramel.
What a disaster.
I've never had a problem with caramel.
[Noel] You've got time.
From one goth to another,
I know you're gonna be fine.
I'll be in my coffin if you want me.
[Helena] I'm just gonna start it again.
♪ I've got time, I've got love ♪
[Sandi] Henry will only have time
for one attempt at his decoration.
[Henry] This is a royal icing little house
to go on the top of the cake.
It's just a bit time-consuming.
Oh, my God, stop shaking.
[Sandi] Henry is studying
English Literature at Durham University,
and in between his studies,
he loves to sing at his local church.
♪ Shall all your cares beguile ♪
[Sandi] He's hoping
to hit all the right notes with his take
on a Wood Street Cake,
an almost 400-year-old recipe
which he'll bring to life
with his royal icing house
and piped chocolate trees.
[Henry] 'Cause a Wood Street Cake
looks quite plain,
so I just wanted to embellish it a bit.
I've gotta build this.
That's another thing.
It looks quite nice laid out.
I think you've done an amazing job
to get it this far.
-Look forward to it.
-Thank you very much.
[Noel] Bakers, you have half an hour left.
-No one looked up.
-[laughing] No, nobody.
Everyone just went, "We've got watches,
what's the point of this?"
-[timer beeping]
-That's yours, Michelle.
[Michelle] I'm just gonna have a look.
[Noel] There's more to baking fruitcake
than meets the eye.
It does look done,
but now I'm like, "Is it done?"
[Noel] With so much fruit inside,
if they're not cooked for long enough,
the centre could still be raw.
[David] It's brown on top.
I mean, I don't know
what it's gonna be like in the middle.
[Sandi] But achieving the perfect bake...
[grunts]
...isn't their only concern.
-Is yours out the oven yet?
-[Phil] No, not yet.
[Alice] I don't wanna leave it too long.
-Breathe, you'll be fine.
-[inhales sharply]
[Sandi] The bakers need
to leave enough time for the cakes to cool
before they can start to decorate.
[Alice] At home,
I iced it when it was still warm
and it just waterfalled down the side,
which is not where I want it.
I'm gonna go in. I can't wait any more.
I'm gonna stick a skewer in
to see if it's cooked.
And that should come out
pretty much clean,
but if it hits the fruit, you can get
a bit of sort of gunky stuff on it.
That's really not clean, is it?
No, it's not ready.
Not done, not done, not done.
Bail, bail, bail.
Not done.
[Henry] Oh, it's cooked.
It's actually cooked.
-[Phil] Spot-on.
-[Priya] Oh, yeah!
This is going in the fridge. Immediately.
[Dan] That's not done.
I perhaps should've been
a lot more prepared.
Bakers, just 15 minutes.
Ooh.
I feel like I've got a sweat on.
It's happened again.
It's not caramelising.
So, I thought I'd just pour the sugar
and see if it sets.
If it doesn't work,
I'm gonna be really gutted.
-[Henry] Oh, the shakes. Oh, the shakes.
-[Noel] Look at that.
-That's an intricate job.
-[Henry] Thank you.
But I just need to get this
on the top of the cake now.
-How you gonna do it?
-Erm...
-Just like... Just pick it up.
-Just pick it up. [laughs]
[Amelia] Right, is it ready?
It's gonna have to come out.
I'm not happy.
Pretty certain
it's not gonna cool in time.
[Rosie] I'm gonna pop it in the freezer,
and I'm gonna stab it
with some really cold skewers.
It's probably a really bad plan.
Just do strange things to cakes sometimes.
[Michelle] Mine's boiling hot.
So, as long as it comes out of the tin
and it doesn't break in half,
I'll be fine.
[Alice] This is the tricky bit.
[Amelia] Let's go for it
and see what happens.
[Phil] Moment of truth.
Oh, yes.
Happy with that.
I'll put 'em back in the fridge.
[gasps] That looks okay.
[Amelia] Why is it not working? Come on.
Oh.
Bit of it got stuck. [exclaims]
Bakers, you've got five minutes left.
-Really?
-Ooh!
[sing-songy]
My cake's too hot. My cake's too hot.
[Amelia] I think that bit goes there.
I didn't expect to be doing this
with basically one hand.
This is just like liquidised sugar.
I've gotta do something.
[Phil] And just let the rum icing
run down the side.
-[Helena] It's beautiful.
-Thank you, darling.
I'm just trying to cool it down quickly.
It's just so hot.
He's doing the thing.
-[chuckling] Does it work?
-No.
[Michael laughs]
[Rosie] It's already melting.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Cake's still too hot,
it's pulling the cake apart.
No, no, it's bending. Damn it.
They've gone "hmm".
I'm popping this on. Give me one sec
'cause the hands are shaking.
[Michelle] My God, I can feel my heart
pounding out of my chest.
-[David] Do you want a hand?
-If you can make the brittle brittle.
[exhales sharply]
Oh, balls.
The worst has happened.
[chuckles]
-Oh, my God.
-The actual worst.
Bakers, your time is up.
[Sandi] That's it,
end of your first challenge.
[sighs]
[Sandi] Please place your cakes
at the end of your benches.
[breathes heavily]
-First one, bagged.
-You've nailed that.
[Dan] Not good.
What a mess.
Ugh.
[Henry] The word "infuriating"
does not sum up that feeling.
[Sandi] The bakers will now face
the judgment of Paul and Prue
for the very first time.
-[Prue] Hello, Priya.
-Hello.
Hi, Priya.
I love the decoration.
It's simplistic, but effective.
[Noel] I'm getting Wham! video.
-[Priya] Yeah, "Club Tropicana".
-Yeah.
[Paul] Let's have a look inside.
-Looks like a good piece of cake.
-Wow.
[Prue] Lovely colour.
-I think you've got what you asked for.
-[sighs]
It's light, it's very summery.
The tropical fruits in there,
it gives it that gorgeous citrus flavour.
-I think it's a well-baked...
-Original.
...different cake.
-[Priya and Paul] Thank you.
-[Prue] Excellent.
[whispers] Nailed it.
[sighs]
[Paul] It's got a very Easter feel,
hasn't it?
He made eyeless chicks.
He didn't want them to see the horror
of your judging. [laughs]
[Prue laughs]
[Paul] It holds together beautifully.
That is delicious.
It is mostly marzipan, which I love.
The fruit content in there is perfect.
That's a great bake. It's a great flavour.
-Well done.
-Thank you very much.
Absolutely destroyed that.
[Henry] It was a hut,
but it's now a little bit of a wreck.
My hands were a bit shaky.
-[Noel] I saw it. It looked amazing.
-[Henry] Noel did see it.
-It looked beautiful.
-[Henry] I promise you he saw it.
[Prue] More important is the bake.
Henry, you have made a very good cake.
Oh, thank God.
I think the texture's beautiful,
it's well-baked.
I think it's a great cake.
Yay! Thank you.
Lovely definition, great colour.
I like the stars as well.
-[Prue] Did that bit stick a bit?
-A little bit, yeah.
[Paul] Well, you can't say
there's no fruit in there.
[laughter]
It's very moist, but I think the flavour
is absolutely lovely.
It screams Christmas.
That's a great tea loaf. Well done.
Ah! [laughs]
Do you know,
I think it looks absolutely beautiful.
I like the way you've iced
between the ridges,
which you've got out
of the tin perfectly.
-Oh, my goodness.
-[Paul] Marzipan right down the middle.
[Prue] Perfect.
-Quite spicy.
-And that's all you get.
You don't really get the fruit.
Just think the flavours
are slightly out of balance.
-Okay. Thank you.
-[Prue and Paul] Thank you.
[whispers] So close.
[sighs]
I had trouble with the decoration.
Just could not work it out.
-If it's not right, don't put them on.
-Lesson learned, yeah.
It is very spicy.
[Paul] It's almost savoury.
I quite like it actually.
I've never had anything like it before.
When you put the icing on,
was the cake still warm, I take it?
Yes, it was.
[Prue] Which is why
the drip hasn't really worked.
[Paul] But I think it looks attractive,
good colour.
[sighs]
[Noel] That's not the noise
you wanna hear, is it?
-[Michelle] No.
-[imitates sigh]
[laughing]
Texture is a little bit tough for me,
but I think the flavour is fantastic.
Okay, thank you.
I think it's
a great-looking cake actually.
Great colour.
[Prue] Very nice.
-[Paul] It's a juicy cake, isn't it?
-[Prue] It's delicious.
[Paul] The apricot
comes through beautifully.
I just want to pick up that slice
-and walk out with it.
-Feel free.
I can't, I've got a few more...
I was gonna say
you've got a few more left. [laughs]
The cake looks a little bit sad.
-It does.
-[Paul] A bit flat.
Shall we have a taste of it?
I'm hoping it'll be lovely anyway.
-Cinnamon.
-Mm.
You've gone a little bit
overboard with that.
It's very chewy,
and it hints at being underbaked.
Hmm. Back to the drawing board.
It's a lovely-looking loaf.
Very good marzipan.
Maybe slightly too much almond essence.
[Paul] The moistness, great.
The texture is perfect.
I think if you'd pulled back
on the almond essence,
you would've had a perfect loaf.
You'd hang that on a door,
wouldn't you?
-[Alice chuckles]
-Well, it is a wreath.
-[Paul] Christmastime.
-[Prue] Christmas wreath.
-[Paul] I love ginger.
-Yeah, it's got a kick to it.
It has.
The crystallised ginger is beautiful.
You could've pulled back a little bit
on the other ginger.
Nice idea.
Sometimes, going back to basics...
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Don't try and overdo something.
The decoration is beautifully done
in spite of having your fingers up...
It's like a pincer. [laughing]
I think the flavour is absolutely lovely.
[Paul] I think you've created
a very good tea cake.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Well done.
Not bad considering
you've only got one finger.
[laughs]
-You look a bit nervous.
-[chuckles] Yeah, can't see why.
[Prue] Well, it certainly does look
a bit rustic.
[Paul] You added more fruit to this,
didn't you?
Yeah.
[Paul] I'm gonna check to see
whether you managed to bake that
all the way through.
I'm not sure.
That's a big slice.
-[Prue] I'm afraid he was right.
-[laughing] Oh, my, God.
[Paul] That's raw.
The alcohol you've got in there
actually tastes quite nice.
I think your flavours are good,
I just think your baking's way out.
I knew that. Thanks for confirming.
[laughs]
[sighs]
That went well. [laughs]
I think he said the flavour
of the booze was good.
That's all I heard. [laughing]
It went really well! [laughs]
I'm absolutely buzzing.
[Steph] I really hope my great-grandma
Rosie was looking down on me.
I think she was there.
Kind of a bit shocked.
That was all right.
Next one, try not to cut off
any more limbs.
[Priya] I'm really chuffed.
I feel like I'm in a good place
going into the Technical.
What's the worst that can happen? [laughs]
[duck quacking]
[Noel] The bakers were able
to practise their fruitcakes,
but their next challenge
is their first gingham-shrouded mystery.
[exhales]
[Sandi] Hello, bakers, and welcome
to your very first Technical Challenge,
which today has been set for you
by Prudence. Any advice?
The secret of success is accuracy.
Yeah, I have that on a tapestry.
-[chuckling]
-[Noel] As ever,
your Technical Challenge
will be judged blind,
so we're gonna have to ask
Prudence and Paulette to leave the tent.
[Sandi] Yeah, off you go.
Do you know what they're up to?
Paul's bought two leotards
and a pommel horse.
Ah, PE lesson.
-[laughter]
-[Sandi] Right.
So, for your Technical Challenge,
Prue would like you to make
six identical angel cake slices.
Each made of three layers
of Genoese sponge.
Now, the sponge layers must be sandwiched
with a silky-smooth
Italian meringue buttercream.
Your angel cake slices should be
topped with icing and feathered.
-Whatever that may be.
-Feathers on cakes?
You've got an hour and three-quarters.
On your marks...
-Get set.
-Bake.
[Amelia] Oh, God.
I didn't want a Genoese sponge
and what have we got?
Genoese sponge.
[Jamie] I love an angel cake,
but I like the cheap one,
like, the 50p job.
Like, this is a proper one.
[Sandi] To make the angel cakes,
the bakers have all been given
the same ingredients
and Prue's complex 15-stage recipe.
This is a bit, as they say, "technical".
It's so complicated.
There's a lot of room for error here,
huge error.
Great choice, Prue.
Angel cake slices for the first Technical
these bakers will have to face.
I am feeling a little mean.
It sounds simple enough,
but the point is it's a Genoese sponge,
and it's really easy for that mixture
to become flat.
If they over-mix,
it's not just volume they'll lose,
the texture becomes rubbery,
and it has to be light.
Now let's have a taste.
[Paul] Takes me back, actually,
to when I was a kid.
You get the raspberry, you get the lemon.
I've just got a vanilla one.
The flavours are delicate,
but strong enough.
I think it tastes delicious.
I think it's a great challenge.
We don't know what the bakers are like.
We're beginning to get to know them,
and I think that's a pretty cruel
Technical Challenge. Great though.
-[laughs]
-Great though.
-You like a bit of cruelty.
-[laughing] I do, yeah.
That starts them off on the right foot.
[Amelia] "First fold the foil paper
to divide the cake tin
into three even sections."
Got some maths in here.
So it could go brilliantly
or it could go horribly.
Just a little bit of origami
at the moment.
Because of my Signature this morning,
I've definitely got a lot more pressure.
But luckily, the instructions so far
look pretty clear.
So far. I'm only on step one.
Right, so, "For the Genoese,
tip the eggs and sugar into a bowl,
whisk the mixture
until it reaches 43 degrees."
I've never made a Genoese.
Damn it. [chuckles]
[Noel] If the bakers
don't whisk for long enough...
This is where I get a good strong arm.
[Noel] ...they won't get enough
air into the Genoese sponge
to create the volume
that Prue is expecting.
When I've made Genoese in the past,
it just ends up hard like a slipper.
Oh.
Okay, how many angel cake slices
have you made in your lifetime?
-Er, none.
-[Sandi chuckles] None.
-None, none, none.
-That's because you're 12.
Do I look that young?
That's why I get ID'd.
-Is that what it is? Do you?
-Everywhere I go. Yeah.
I got ID'd in Arizona.
It was very dark, just saying.
-[laughing]
-It was really, really dark.
Forty-three degrees.
We are done. Come off.
Whew!
"Whisk the mixture into ribbon stage."
Fine. Okay.
-We're gonna go fast.
-[Henry] God, it takes a while.
[Phil] "When you lift up the whisk
and you draw it over the batter,
it leaves like a ribbon effect."
I kind of think that's ribbon stage.
[David] This, I think, is perfect.
[Phil] "Meanwhile,
divide the flour and the butter evenly
between three small bowls."
One, two, three.
I've literally got 1,000 bowls on here.
[Sandi] Prue's expecting
three layers of Genoese sponge...
So we've got lemon, raspberry and vanilla.
[Sandi] ...each with
a different colour and flavour.
It's like that thing where you go...
[imitates glass harp music]
Have you made these before?
Tried Genoese once and botched it.
-Don't say that on the camera.
-Too late. [laughs]
-Good luck.
-Thank you.
-[imitates glass harp music]
-[chuckles]
It doesn't tell us how much
of the vanilla or raspberry or anything,
so you're just gonna have to judge
how strong you think
the flavour should be.
[Steph] We don't want it to be lacking.
-Teaspoon?
-Cup and a half?
[Michelle] Gonna go half.
Oh, go on then, two. [chuckles]
Okay, so raspberry flavouring
and pink food gel.
-[Dan] I don't know how much of that.
-I'm thinking quite a pale pink.
Looks good enough to me.
I'm not gonna put
all of the lemon zest in.
It's a big lemon,
so that's still quite a bit.
-[Amelia] Oh, that is a lot of yellow.
-Orange, yellow. It's a spectrum.
[Alice] "Working with one bowl at a time,
sieve the flour over the egg,
add the butter and fold it through."
So, you fold it really gently
'cause you've whisked all the air into it.
You don't wanna knock it out.
[Alice] Just trying not to over-mix it,
but just wanna get the colour
to spread throughout.
Gently, gently.
Don't want to upset the judges.
I don't know if I've over-whisked it
or not, but it's gone flat, basically.
-What's wrong?
-It's just got... It's got no air in it.
This is gonna be flat as a pancake.
I need to start again.
[Noel] I don't know how
to make this app work.
-That's 'cause it's a Technical Challenge.
-Oh.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
So, "Pour the three batters
into the sections of the tins
and then bake it."
[David] If you look at the yellow one,
it's half the volume of the pink one.
But I don't have time to do it again.
I'm just redoing my sponges.
I don't know why
this is confusing me so much.
I'm going in.
-How long for?
-No, there's no telling us.
Seven minutes, eight minutes,
something like that and check it.
I don't know. I'll just keep my eye on it.
[Priya] I'm a bit worried
'cause it's so thin,
it is so easy to overbake it.
I'm nervous, I'm nervous.
-[Sandi] And in time call news...
-Bakers, you've got half an hour left.
-What?
-That's all from us.
Oh, that's no good, is it?
I'm gonna run out of time.
I need to make the Italian meringue.
I actually know how to make that.
"Slowly pour the hot syrup
onto the egg whites."
Then she says, "Add the butter until
the buttercream is smooth and thick."
Should go nice and glossy.
It looks okay at the moment.
I've come to love you, Jamie,
'cause I think you might need it.
-Yeah, it's failed again, so...
-[Sandi] What went wrong?
-It turned out like this.
-Okay.
And then I tried to make it again.
-A bit lumpy.
-And then it got even worse.
-So, now I'm--
-It is a bit lumpy, darling.
It's... It's rubbish.
It's not even worth putting that in.
I'm gonna do two layers.
[Priya] These have been in for 12 minutes.
Yeah, I'm getting it out.
I don't know if this is meant
to look like this.
[Dan] I said I was putting them
in the oven for ten minutes.
Still says ten minutes.
I never started the timer.
Ooh, they look a bit like an Aero.
They're about twice the height of mine.
[Helena] Seriously,
my sponge is like rubber. [chuckles]
It looks all right actually.
So, "Sandwich with buttercream."
This is not buttercream,
this is meringue. So bad.
I've not had any angel cakes before.
Hopefully, this is right.
It's not looking quite right,
But I'm making the buttercream.
I'm not gonna do nothing.
"Cover with the white fondant icing
and feather with the pink."
[Alice] I'm not sure whether
to ice it and then cut it,
or to cut it and then ice it.
[Henry] I'm going for ice, then slice.
It says to do that.
I'm being very obedient.
Five minutes left.
We've got five minutes?
Don't panic! Don't panic!
[Jamie] Look at that.
They might actually refuse to try it.
I literally wouldn't be surprised.
It is rubber. [chuckles nervously]
I'm not even just saying that.
It is rubber.
So I've gotta draw some lines.
Never feathered before.
The secret to feathering
is a sharp cocktail stick and wet icing.
Mine has gone mental.
What the hell did I get myself into?
[Dan] My hands are shaking a bit.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
-No.
-[Jamie] Oh, my days.
[Alice] My hands are shaking so much.
There's a chance of them being like,
"Literally that's inedible."
If it fell on the floor,
it'll bounce right back.
[Priya] I can say with confidence
I won't be winning this challenge.
Cut it into six, right?
Enough for everyone. [chuckles]
[Noel] Bakers, that is the end
of your Technical Challenge.
Phew!
Oh, well.
Well done, everybody.
Please bring your bakes up to the table
and place them
in front of your photograph.
[Jamie] They're not gonna eat it.
It's inedible, like, literally.
-Dan, do you wanna swap?
-[laughs]
[Noel] Prue and Paul will now judge
the bakers' first Technical Challenge.
They're expecting
six identical angel cake slices
filled with silky
Italian meringue buttercream
and topped with a feathered fondant icing.
Okay.
It's lost all the height and the spring
in the sponge, and that red is too much.
[Prue] Where's the silky smooth
Italian buttercream?
-That's melted.
-It's not there. It's melted out.
Flavours are there, but it's like rubber.
If I dropped that on the floor,
it'd bounce up and hit me in the face.
-[chuckles]
-[Prue] This one's feathering's better.
[Paul] However, still not
as high as they should be.
The flavours are there.
[Prue] Too much icing on the top, I think.
[Paul] Moving on, these look all the same.
I mean, that is much higher, isn't it?
And it's pink rather than red.
-It's got nice flavours in there.
-Mmm. Yeah, that's not bad.
I think this is another,
not to mince words, failure.
[Paul] Where's the bottom layer?
It's missing one.
[all laugh]
Do you know,
it actually tastes rather nice.
[all laugh]
We're missing a layer,
and rubbery to taste as well.
This looks a little bit more delicate.
There's a bit of height to that sponge.
[Prue] And everything is pastel shades.
-Mmm. It tastes delicious.
-Yeah, and the raspberry one's okay.
-[Prue] Right.
-[Paul] I like the feathering on this.
They are fairly equal.
Buttercream's good. Nice flavour.
Okay, moving on again.
It's very thin, it's lost all its height.
[Prue] But the buttercream
looks beautiful. They're not bad.
Hmm, a bit rubbery.
This looks quite delicate,
however, the two sponges look the same.
[Prue] And the lemon should have
a little bit of colour.
-Ooh, it's a bit tough.
-[Paul] Hmm, it is.
Now, I like the feathering
on that one. It's very neat.
[Prue] And that looks jolly tough.
It's just dried a bit on the edges,
but it's not that tough.
[Paul] Talk about neat. That's not.
And the sponge is okay,
but they're still not high enough.
-[Prue] Mm.
-[Paul] The flavours are okay.
-Moving on, it's the highest one.
-[Prue] The height is really good.
[Paul] And soft.
I mean, it's hideous fondant on the top.
[Prue] It's very good cake though.
[Paul] And you move on to this.
[Prue] Lots of buttercream,
not bad feathering.
Flavours are all right.
It's certainly got the height, that one.
Last but maybe least,
we've got very thin layers again.
[Prue] It's nice shiny fondant.
-[Paul] Quite tough.
-[Prue] Very tough.
[Sandi] Prue and Paul
will now rank the cakes
from worst to best.
This number 13, who's responsible for it?
Jamie, it was pretty awful.
-Thank you.
-[all laugh]
-Twelfth spot is this one.
-That was me.
Not surprised. Blood red in the middle,
and a bit rubbery.
Number 11 is this one.
-Michael.
-Sorry.
[Prue] It tasted nice
but they were pretty uneven.
[Noel] David is tenth, ninth Dan,
eighth Phil, seventh Priya,
sixth Michelle, Alice is fifth
and Amelia is fourth.
Now, number three was this one. Stephanie.
I mean, your icing was terrible.
-Thank you.
-[all chuckle]
But the flavour matters
more than anything.
And number two...
is this one.
Erm, not bad at all.
Nice bit of feathering, nice and equal,
and the buttercream was good.
[Prue] Which means
that this one is number one.
-Henry, well done.
-[cheers and applause]
Very good feathering
and excellent in every way, really.
-So, well done.
-Thank you very much. Thank you.
To win the first Technical, that feels
just quite... quite pleasing.
Second, awesome, chuffed with that.
After this morning, I needed that.
I sort of feel
that I've clawed my way back
and I'm not bottom-bottom any more.
The Technical was supposed to be
the one that saved me. [laughs]
It didn't quite, so it's all
on the Showstopper tomorrow.
If that doesn't go well, I'm a goner.
[Jamie] I knew midway through
that I was gonna come last,
but I just wanted to
get something fairly...
Well, it wasn't even respectable, was it?
Something on the plate. [laughs]
[chirping]
[indistinct chatter]
[Sandi] Just one challenge remains
before the first Star Baker is crowned,
and one baker will have to leave the tent.
Hello, bakers.
It's time for your first ever Showstopper.
[Sandi] So today, Paul and Prue
would like you to make a birthday cake,
but not just any old birthday cake.
They want the birthday cake
you dreamt of as a child.
[Noel] The cake that
I dreamt of as a child
had marzipan arms
and we just held hands together.
-[chuckling]
-[Sandi] That's nice.
-[Noel] Yeah.
-Weirdo.
Okay, the flavours, fillings
and decorations are entirely up to you,
but please remember, it is a Showstopper,
it needs to be spectacular and sizeable.
[Noel] You've got four hours.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
Bake.
Pfft.
Every minute, there's, like,
100% always something to do.
It's gonna be full-on, a busy four hours.
Mayhem is the best word for it.
[sing-songy] We will see.
[Paul] Time will be their enemy.
It's all about colour, it's about detail,
it's about "wow".
They've gotta show us what they can do.
[Dan] That's going in the oven.
-[laughter]
-[David] You're kidding me.
-[Jamie] Oh, right, you're joking?
-Not funny.
[Prue] I'm rather hoping
for some originality.
Children dream a lot. I want them to try
to remember what they dreamt about.
But as always, what matters
far more than anything
is the quality of the cake.
The flavours should be real and punchy.
It has to be delicious.
I think it gives us a chance
to dig around in the bakers' skills
and find out a little bit
about our baker's dozen.
[Paul] Good morning.
-Oh, hey.
-Hello, Helena.
So, it's obviously chocolate cake.
Tell us what you're gonna make
with the cake.
It's, er, a fairy garden.
I had a fairy garden as a child.
I have one now.
[Paul] You've got a what, sorry?
[Helena] A fairy garden now.
[Noel] You've got a fairy garden.
Fairy... Is it my accent?
Oh, a fairy garden.
-[Prue] What did you think she said?
-Well, like, fur.
Furry garden? No, fairy garden.
[laughing] Oh, Paul,
I know what you're thinking.
[Sandi] Helena's
perfectly manicured fairy garden
will be covered in green desiccated
coconut grass and chocolate tree bark.
So, how big is your, erm...
-erm, fairy garden?
-[laughter]
[Prue] You're gonna put these two
and then these two?
-[Helena] Correct, yeah.
-So, it's a fairy mountain.
-[Helena] Yeah, yeah, it will--
-[laughter]
Oh, God, I can't do it.
[Sandi] Helena's not the only baker...
I better not put my hands in there.
[Sandi] ...away with the fairies.
I am making a Tŷ Tylwyth Teg,
which means "fairy cake" in Welsh.
[Sandi] Featuring a toadstool house
built out of carrot cake,
Michelle's inspiration also comes
from childhood fantasies
of fairies living
at the bottom of the garden.
My sister and I,
we always found that really magical.
It's something that reminds me
of my childhood,
so it's something I want to do today.
[Sandi] Steph's Showstopper is based
on a childhood memory she'd rather forget.
[Prue] This is a really sweet picture.
[Steph] I loved ice cream,
but I'm a little bit accident-prone, so...
-You dropped it.
-[Steph] Splat, yeah.
[Noel] Carved out of coconut
and raspberry-ripple cake,
Steph's hoping
her giant upside-down ice cream
won't slip through her fingers
a second time.
[Prue] Have you practised this?
I've done it
in varying degrees of success,
so one extremely good, but one less good
with a small amount of sinkage.
There's no real going back at this point.
I've just gotta hope.
[Sandi] The taller the Showstopper...
Something like that hopefully.
Substantial.
[Sandi] ...the more robust
the sponge will need to be
to hold the weight
of the bakers' supersized creations.
[David] I'm putting things
like glycerine inside,
trying to do things to make it
a very moist cake, but still solid,
so it can stand up on itself.
It's a balance.
[Sandi]
For her ambitious three-tier design...
[Priya] A lot of cake mix.
[Sandi] ...Priya's not taking any chances.
[Priya] It's quite a simple batter.
It just needs enough structure for me
to be able to carve bits of it off
without it all falling apart.
[Noel] Priya's sturdy
chocolate and orange sponge
will be shaped and decorated
to look like a child's pop-up storybook.
[Priya] I've always loved books.
When I was younger,
I used to write my own little stories.
"The Easter Bunny Who Lost His Eggs"
and "Sally Sue's Glasses".
I took the trouble to, er,
put copyright and an ISBN number.
What sort of ten-year-old does that?
There you go. That was me as a child.
[Sandi]
English Literature student Henry...
I've made quite a few
birthday cakes at uni.
That was in the year
where everyone's got their 21st,
so the kitchen's been carnage.
[Sandi] ...is also drawing
on his lifelong love of books.
I've based it around
The Magic Faraway Tree.
It's a really freaky book reading it now,
but I loved it as a child.
Are you doing any of the weird characters?
-There's Moon-Face.
-[Noel] Moon-Face.
-[both laugh]
-I'm not doing Moon-Face.
-Based my career on Moon-Face.
-[all laugh]
[Sandi] Henry's magic tree
will stand in its own
three-tiered triple-chocolate
magical wood.
I've tried to get the sort of
woodland berry flavours into it.
And it shouldn't be too sweet either
'cause children's birthday cakes
can be sickly.
Tone that down a bit.
Somewhere between a child's dream
and this judge's taste buds.
[Henry] That was the plan.
[Noel] One baker indulging
in his childhood self is Jamie.
[Jamie] It's like a salted caramel sponge
with salted caramel buttercream
and caramel sauce.
I guess it's my favourite flavour
as I was younger.
My twin brother Alex likes this as well.
It's kind of a cake for all of us.
[Noel] Based on
his family's beloved schnauzer dogs,
cartoonish canine fondant features
will be the icing
on Jamie's dream birthday cake.
Haven't gone really big,
it's just a single tier,
but I should have enough time
to get it all done
and not be rushing around
like I was yesterday.
I don't know why my batter's,
like, really stiff.
I don't think I added too much flour.
I don't know why it would be like that.
Oh, my goodness.
I forgot to add the eggs.
Rosie, I forgot to add my eggs.
[Rosie] Oh, no. Can you add them now?
No, I'll have to start again.
It's not worth the risk, is it?
No wonder I was, like... [grunts]
It was like mixing concrete. [laughs]
Wow, already messed up.
That's good, isn't it?
Bakers, you only have three hours left.
Thought he was about to say "minutes"
for some reason.
That first hour went like that.
-[laughter]
-It's like déjà vu, isn't it?
[Sandi] Whilst Jamie has to
start his cake batter once again...
Are you warm? You are warm.
[Sandi] ...everyone else
is ready to begin baking.
Straight in.
[Alice] So I'm just gonna do
two at a time.
[Sandi]
But with multiple cakes needed
to construct their
spectacular creations...
[Michael] Two down, two to go.
[Sandi] ...most are having
to bake in batches.
And now I'm gonna do that all over again.
[Noel] With so much cake to support,
Alice is baking some reinforcements.
I'm just making some lemon butter biscuits
which are going to form some walls
and a roof for my sweetshop.
Both my parents are dentists, so as a kid,
sweets weren't really on the menu.
[Noel] Alice will be decorating
lemon and raspberry-flavoured sponge
to look like a sweetshop
with its own iced-biscuit canopy.
[Alice] Have to be quite careful
that it's strong enough,
that the roof doesn't collapse.
Bit of a sag in one of my practices,
so need to make sure
they are structurally sound.
[Sandi] To avoid total collapse
without scaling back
on the size of their Showstoppers...
It is literally just marshmallows
and Rice Krispies.
[Sandi] ...Amelia, David and Phil
are all using
a lightweight cake alternative.
Because it's easy to mould
and I haven't gotta make another cake,
so I'm just shaping the nose cone
for the rocket.
[Noel] Hoping to blast himself
back up the scoreboard,
Phil's towering rocket-shaped
and sherbet-flavoured sponge cake
will be a nostalgic nod
to the 1969 Moon landings.
[Sandi] There's a great story of when, er,
the Russians first sent a satellite
into space, it was called "Sputnik".
First one the Americans sent in,
it crashed immediately
and they called it "Kaputnik",
which I quite like.
[laughs]
[Noel] Amelia is trying to figure
out how to avoid a "Kaputnik" of her own.
[Amelia] I am doing a carousel cake.
And there might be a tube
in the middle of the carousel,
depending on time and my nerves
and everything else.
[Noel] Inside Amelia's carousel
will be red velvet sponge,
and she's hoping to have pink candy horses
merrily going around her precarious pole.
The, like, logistics of sticking it,
balancing my cone on top...
Yeah, it's just stressful.
[Sandi] David's Showstopper...
It's gonna be scary.
[Sandi] ...is just as intimidating.
It's gonna be a snake, basically.
-Snake?
-[David] Yeah.
When I was a kid,
I had an albino Burmese python.
I had a garter snake.
I had a slow-worm.
Some of us have got snakes,
some of us have got worms, Paul.
[all laugh]
[Sandi] Fiercely protecting
an egg full of baby jelly snakes,
David's terrifying
chocolate and orange snake cake
will be complete with a tongue,
fangs and snakeskin.
[David] I'm going with netting from
a packet of oranges and then spraying it.
I saw it on a makeup programme.
Someone was doing a snake.
It looks a bit like
when they shed their skin, doesn't it?
[David] Yeah, I might just
put that at the side afterwards then.
[chuckles] Good luck.
Brilliant, thank you very much.
Bakers, you are halfway through,
halfway through.
-[Michelle groans]
-Two hours left.
Let's hurry now a bit.
I've done about 20 minutes' work.
I had a safety net
which has all been used up probably.
But I'm looking better than before.
-[Phil] They're coming out now.
-Must not drop cake.
[Sandi] While the first batch of cakes
are coming out of the oven...
So far, so good.
[Sandi] ...there's still
plenty more to be baked.
Got my biggest cakes out of the oven.
My little ones are in the oven.
[timer beeping]
[Sandi] And if keeping track
of multiple baking...
Chill out.
[Sandi] ...and cooling times
isn't hard enough...
What was that timer for?
[Sandi] ...they've still got to find time
to make dozens of decorative elements...
[Rosie] This is probably
gonna make a mess.
[Sandi] ...to turn
their childhood dreams into reality.
I am making a jungle cake.
This is gonna be my tree,
which I am relying on
for, like, the whole cake, really.
[Noel] Clinging on
to Rosie's chocolate tree
will be a fondant monkey
and our second coiled snake,
a familiar sight for our baking vet.
Yeah, someone once brought in
a giant snake in my last job
and it wrapped itself around
my boss's computer.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah, I was literally going,
"Er, do I have to replace the computer
if the snake squishes it? Er..."
[Sandi laughs] How do you persuade a snake
to let go of a computer?
Just sort of waited
and sort of pulled its tail a bit,
you know, gently, and hoped.
-[Sandi] Wow.
-It let go. It was fine.
[Michael] These are gold bars
made out of cinder toffee,
because when I was wee,
I had a pirate party
and my mum made
this amazing treasure-chest cake,
so I'm gonna give it a go myself.
[Sandi] Michael's treasure chest
will be heaving with cinder toffee gold
and precious gems
made out of molten sugar.
[Michael] Right, here we go.
It sort of needs to fill to the very top,
'cause otherwise you don't get
the full gem effect.
Ooh, nearly.
Ruined.
Right, I need to just move on.
[Sandi] Not only does
Michael's treasure need to set,
it's also at risk
of being plundered by Dan.
I'm baking a pirate island cake.
I've just heard what Michael's doing.
I didn't copy it. [laughs]
[Sandi] Dan's pirate island will be formed
from five tiers of lime
and coconut sponge.
And after a disastrous first day,
he's hoping he won't have
to walk the plank.
[Noel] You've pulled it out,
haven't you, for this one?
-I'm trying.
-You don't wanna go home first, do you?
[laughs] No, I definitely don't.
If you go home first,
I will pull the tent down.
-We'll do it together.
-That's it. [chuckles]
-We'll graffiti Paul's car.
-[laughing]
-[Dan] Let's do that, yeah.
-We'll hide Prue's glasses.
So, Prue, dream birthday cake Showstopper,
I mean, I think it's a great challenge
because I think it allows the bakers
to really bring their personality out.
The only big issue I think they're
all gonna have is finishing it off,
'cause the last thing we want is just
a sponge with no decorative element to it.
It's the decoration
that will let them down.
[Michelle] I haven't actually finished
the whole thing decorated at home.
I've always been about 20 minutes over.
Pressure's on now to make sure I do.
Bakers, you have one hour remaining.
One hour.
[Priya groans]
[mouths]
Just enough time for me to do my fringe.
[Michael laughs]
One hour is a bit tight.
Starting to feel the pressure.
[Jamie] It's good, came out clean,
so let it cool before
I put the fondant on.
So, are you happy?
At the moment, yeah. I'm, like, maybe
a bit behind now, but I hope it works.
If you want me to push anyone's cake
on the floor, just let me know.
-Dan's looking too comfortable. [laughs]
-Dan, all right.
I'll push it on the floor.
See you in a bit.
I think I need to start assembling.
Everyone else is starting to begin.
[Sandi] Only when
all of their cakes are cooled...
Been in the fridge for 45 minutes
so they're nice and cold now.
[Sandi] ...can construction begin...
[Dan] Not too much of a problem.
Just do that.
Once it gets iced,
that should be all right.
[Sandi] ...and the strength
of their sponges will be put to the test.
[Dan] There you go, you would never know.
[Michael] I dropped my cake.
-[Amelia] You okay?
-[Michael] No.
Oh, my God. [laughs]
I think it's okay.
Oh, I think I've got
a stress hernia. [exhales]
[Noel]
If the bakers don't carve...
[Priya] This is the book,
so it'll be, like, sloped on the edges.
[Noel] ...stack...
[Steph] I'm slicing the top
so that the cake is level.
[Noel]
...and shape with precision...
I just don't want it to go too deep
that it's going to collapse my cake.
[Noel] ...their entire
Showstopper structures could collapse.
Vanilla buttercream
going between the layers.
Let's just hope they glue it together.
[Dan] So I'm putting
the passion fruit curd on to sandwich.
I hope the passion fruit's
gonna pack a punch, but we'll see.
I'm just dowling the cake,
which means when I come to stack it,
it won't collapse.
[Alice] Have to be
quite careful with this.
It's just a bit wobbly.
If that doesn't stay up,
then the whole thing will fall down,
so gonna shove these in there.
[Henry] Can't do it.
[snaps]
[Henry whispers] Sorry.
[Dan] I'm covering this in white fondant,
just gonna airbrush the colours onto it.
'Cause I'm doing quite a simple cake,
I think it needs to look almost perfect.
[Rosie] Oh, no. Calm down, calm down,
calm down, calm down.
[Phil] This is the nose cone.
Just trying to use my hands.
This is a tiny little thing
so I gotta be careful with it, really.
Bakers, you have half an hour,
just half an hour.
I can do it in half an hour, I can, I can.
Just add the final layer
and then it's decoration.
How much I do depends on
how much time I have.
This is the last mountain,
but I am worried now about time.
I didn't realise we had as little left.
[exhales] Getting there.
My tree is rubbish.
It's the worst tree I've ever made,
but I'm gonna do my best
to try and fix it.
[Jamie] I'll put the biscuits in.
[Sandi] So, you're gonna split
the dog's head open
-and confetti's gonna come out.
-[Jamie] Yeah.
You know that Rosie's a vet, right?
[Jamie] So you've gotta
stitch it back up again.
Oh, I really don't have time to fix it.
[Dan] This is my isomalt waterfall
which might not have worked out.
Start again.
It's upright, it's whether it can hold.
-Stay.
-Hasn't fallen over yet.
[Phil] Looks a bit unstable to me.
Might have to deconstruct it
until I'm ready.
It's all right.
No pressure.
Bakers, you have ten minutes left.
Just throw food colouring at it,
it will be fine.
[Priya] That's what I'm doing.
[David] Michelle,
do you think you're on time?
-[Michelle] No.
-[David] Close?
Erm... no.
[Jamie] Starting to panic a bit now.
Mine doesn't really look
like a birthday cake, now, does it?
Oh, God, I don't know if I'm gonna
have time to put the tube in the middle,
so this is now gonna sit on there.
[sighs]
Yesterday, the chicks didn't have eyes
but dogs definitely have to have eyes.
Hey, you did a waterfall.
[Dan] Ish.
[Phil] Hopefully it'll stay.
-Bakers, one minute remaining.
-[Phil groans]
[Sandi] That was a happy sound.
[both imitate groaning]
Oh, my days.
Don't worry, it's only
our childhood dreams on the line.
[David] I'm not sure
I can do anything else, can I? [exhales]
[Amelia] Oh, don't run out of icing now.
Like, come on.
I need to just pipe the face.
I might have time. So annoying.
[Dan] I don't think they're gonna stand.
-[sighs]
-Done it. [exhales] Done it.
-[Sandi] Right, beautiful bakers.
-[sputters]
Your time is up.
-All your first bakes are over.
-You did it.
Oh, my God. That is not
what I wanna see when I turn around.
[chuckles, mimics barking]
[Amelia] Dan, that looks sick.
Don't. I feel sick.
[sighs]
[Noel] It's judgment time
for our bakers' dream
childhood birthday cakes.
Michelle, would you bring up
your birthday cake, please?
Wow. It's absolutely exquisite.
I like the detail, and it's neat.
It's tidy.
[Prue] Well, now
it's just gotta taste good.
It is a carrot cake with
orange cream cheese frosting.
[Paul] It's a great-looking carrot cake.
-I'm dribbling.
-[Noel laughs]
Prue, you've gotta stop saying that.
[all laughing]
[Prue] I mean, I'm absolutely salivating.
-I think it's wonderful.
-Oh, thank you.
The balance of spices
that you've put in is perfect.
It's nice and moist inside there,
and the design as well.
It's faultless actually.
-[Sandi] "Faultless".
-[Noel] "Faultless".
-Thank you. Thanks very much.
-[Sandi] Well done.
[applause]
"Faultless". [sighs]
It's very delicate. It's very charming.
Let's see what it tastes like, shall we?
The waft of chocolate is just terrific.
It is a fantastic sponge.
The depth of flavour is beautiful.
You've got coffee in there, which actually
blends beautifully with the chocolate.
I think you've done a good job
with your fairy garden.
-[Helena] Thanks.
-[Prue] Don't start.
[laughter]
That doesn't look like a book.
-Yeah.
-[Prue] This is just a little bit clumsy,
but I love the concept.
I've made a chocolate orange sponge
and chocolate orange buttercream.
If I hadn't just had a better one,
I would've said it was an excellent cake,
but this is slightly drier.
If you'd spent less time
with the cake in the oven
and more time getting it finished,
you probably would've been all right.
It's really impressive,
and it didn't collapse.
It didn't collapse, no.
[Prue] Some of it's a bit rough and ready,
but let's see what it tastes like.
Very light sponge.
-That is a beautiful cake.
-Thank you.
When you do hit the raspberry,
it is deliciously balanced.
It's a bit simplistic
but I think you've done well.
It's so effective.
It makes me feel quite nostalgic.
-[Noel laughs]
-I can remember 1969
-even if you boys can't.
-[laughter]
-First man on the Moon, 1969.
-Exactly, and I watched him land.
It is a good design.
However, it is leaning.
-This is sherbet, isn't it?
-Mm-hmm.
For me, it's a little too sweet.
It needs more sharpness
to balance out the sweetness.
I would never have thought
of that for a cake.
[Paul] The design is spectacular.
I think you've done a good job.
It's a good thing
you've got the blackberries there
because it's quite a sweet cake.
[Paul] You want that rich chocolate.
If you never had that blackberry in there,
I wouldn't like it at all.
[exhales]
[Prue] You've been very restrained
about the colours.
This is a classy grown-up's version
of a child's dream.
-Did you run out of time?
-[Amelia] Yeah.
[Paul] I expected a little bit
more than that.
[Prue] But let's see what it tastes like.
It's a red velvet cake with
white chocolate ganache and raspberry jam.
[Paul] It's a pretty claggy cake.
It doesn't taste good actually.
I see what you were going for
but I think you're slightly off the mark.
-I love the idea that you dropped it.
-[Steph] Yeah.
[Prue] Which happens always
when you've got children on the beach.
Always. Yeah.
[Paul] That's a crumbly cake.
[Steph] It's raspberry ripple and coconut.
I think it must be a bit overbaked
'cause it's a little bit dry as a result.
Yeah, okay.
Flavours are good.
Concentrate on your baking.
Okay.
[Prue] I think it looks
absolutely amazing.
It's charming.
I think it's a fantastic-looking cake.
The egg has something in it as well.
-[Prue] Oh, it's baby snakes.
-[Paul] Ah.
Oh, wow. Brilliant and creepy.
-[laughs]
-[Noel] In a good way.
[David] Yeah.
[Prue] That's a very nice
thin layer of icing, well done.
That is a beautiful cake.
The chocolate, the citrus,
it all marries up lovely,
and to finish it off looking like that,
well done, David.
[Prue] Very, very good cake.
I think it’s a little bit simplistic
for me.
-Okay.
-[Paul] A bit clumsy.
Well, I very seldom disagree with Paul,
but I love the exterior.
Tell us all about your birthday cake.
It’s a red velvet cake
with an Italian meringue buttercream.
[Paul] Nice equal layers.
The cake’s baked beautifully.
The Italian buttercream is silky smooth.
I think the interior for me works,
the exterior doesn’t.
Okay.
-[Prue] Oh, my goodness.
-It looks great.
I think you've ended up with a design
that any kid would be happy getting
on their birthday.
Remind me of those flavours again.
[Michael] It’s a chocolate and coffee
sponge with salted caramel buttercream.
[Paul] It’s a great-looking sponge.
I like the texture, but I think
it needed a bit more chocolate.
It’s good. Just think about your flavours.
-[Prue] I like the gold bars.
-[crunching]
-Very good.
-A couple of big kids.
-[Paul] Well done, Michael. Thank you.
-Thank you.
[Prue] It’s a waterfall.
-Very beautifully done.
-[Paul] It’s clever.
-It’s very clever.
-I mean, I could see kids
-going for that straightaway.
-[Prue] Yeah.
It’s lime and coconut cake
with coconut buttercream
and passion fruit curd.
Strong coconut. Where’s the passion fruit?
-It’s in the curd.
-It’s there, it’s so slight.
There’s more of it in the middle.
[laughing]
[all laugh]
-It’s not there either.
-[Michelle] Oh.
If you go further up, there’s more.
Get it?
-[laughter]
-Not really, no.
Your flavour ideas were sound,
but you’re not bringing it through.
But the design, I think,
is very, very good.
-How many sponges are in there?
-Four.
[Paul] And you got salted caramel
in between each layer?
Yeah, it’s like a... [voice breaks]
Ooh, crikey.
-[laughing] That’s embarrassing.
-[Sandi] Is your voice breaking?
Finally.
[all laughing]
Yeah, it's...
So, it’s got buttercream
and caramel sauce between each layer.
-[Prue] That looks pretty good.
-Oh, I see.
-They're your dog biscuits.
-Yeah.
Actually, those biscuits are really nice.
-Are they? Oh, nice.
-[Prue] Mmm.
One mouthful is lovely.
It’s like eating a toffee.
-Yeah.
-[Prue] But a whole slice would be
overwhelmingly salted caramel.
Your cake’s overbaked.
There’s not a lot of finesse
about this cake.
-Thank you very much.
-Thank you.
Well, that didn’t go well, did it?
[laughs]
I guess you don’t really know
until you’re under pressure
what it’s gonna be like.
Er... [laughs] I don’t know what to say.
Hold on, hold on. "Faultless".
Paul said he didn’t like my cake
during cake week.
Staying in this competition now
would mean everything.
I need a lifeline. Throw me a bone.
I’m just prepared for the worst,
and if it happens, it happens.
Ah. Oh, my God. I don’t wanna get filmed
with tears in my eyes.
So cringe, isn’t it?
[Sandi] Prue and Paul must now
decide who will be our first Star Baker,
and who will be leaving the tent.
That was amazing. I thought
they really came into their own.
Their personalities started to come out.
When we walked into the room,
it was just this sea
of amazing Showstoppers.
My favourite is still the first one.
-Michelle’s cake.
-[Prue] Michelle’s.
[Paul] She did okay in the Technical,
she did well in the Signature,
but this has elevated her.
So, she’s up there or thereabouts.
I think Steph deserves a mention
up there as well.
Steph’s cake was pretty good.
Third in Technical,
she did pretty well in the Signature too.
But Henry, who had done brilliantly
in the Technical,
-not so pleased?
-Henry had a good day yesterday, yeah.
-Today, he’s not done so well.
-[Paul] No, he hasn't.
People for me who are in a little bit
of trouble, I have to say Jamie.
His Signature was good,
but he was bottom of Technical.
Today, he struggled with the Showstopper.
Dan, because I was trying
to hunt down the flavour.
Although the design was pretty good.
But 13 pieces of cake.
Are you all right?
-No.
-Not quite.
[both laugh]
Well done, bakers. That is your first week
in the tent successfully completed.
Sigh of relief, I’m sure.
And I have to tell you, Paul and Prue say
the standard has been incredibly high.
So, well done.
I’ve got the fantastic job
of announcing Star Baker.
The person who is Star Baker
this week is...
Michelle.
-[Michael] Yes.
-[all cheering]
[indistinct chatter]
-Amazing. Well done.
-Thank you.
So, that leaves me with the horrible job
of sending somebody home,
and I have to say,
even after the first week,
it is incredibly difficult, but I’m afraid
one of you has to depart,
and that person is...
Dan. I'm so sorry.
-Bad call, mate.
-[chuckling] I know, mate. I know, mate.
I had a bad week.
[Sandi] Well done, Phil.
Definitely, I’ll take away
the friendships.
-[Phil] What are we gonna do without you?
-[Dan laughs]
Can’t imagine how everyone’s bonded.
It’s so strange.
-[Alice] Aw, Dan.
-[David] He’s such a beautiful man.
I’m not gonna miss
the baking under pressure.
Just gonna miss everybody in that tent.
-[Paul] Sorry, mate.
-[Dan] No, no, it’s all right.
[Paul] He’s a great baker, Dan,
but unfortunately,
it all boiled down to his Signature bake,
and it was that
that was the cause of him going.
Pick it up a bit, all right?
It was really close.
[Jamie] I thought it was gonna be me.
I’m looking forward to coming back
and almost starting again.
Convince people I can bake. [laughs]
Yeah, when you come on
and you can’t even bake a cake properly,
it doesn't look good, does it?
-[Michelle] Oh, my God.
-[Amelia] You must be so pleased.
[Michelle] I can’t get over it.
I’m so shocked.
To get Star Baker, I’m just so proud.
[crying]
[sniffles]
I don’t know what to say. I’m just happy.
-[Prue] Well done, Michelle.
-[Michelle] Thank you so much.
-[Prue] I want the recipe, please.
-[Michelle] Oh.
You know, this is the tenth anniversary,
and what a way to start.
That Showstopper was pretty well
the best cake I’ve ever eaten. [laughs]
-I’ve got something to tell you.
-[Ben] Yeah?
-I'm still in.
-[Ben] Yes!
[Michelle] And, er, Prue Leith wants
my carrot cake recipe.
[Ben laughs] Mich!
Er, and I’m Star Baker.
-[Ben] Oh, my God!
-[laughing]
[Ben] Couldn’t be prouder.
Do you know what? I knew you could do it.
I’ve had a cry as well.
[Ben] Yeah, I’m close to that as well.
[both laugh]
[Michael] Group hug. Group hug. Group hug.
Get 'em in. Get 'em in.
-[laughter]
-[Michelle] Aw.